hold up did you know that if you press
the pause button right now come across
to the like button and then refresh this
video it's going to be an entirely
different thing
well let's be honest it's going to be
that anyway but you might as well hit
the like button so we can get started
with today's video today we're talking
about the absolute perfect architectural
office what you can do to create your
very own so let's start this video by
shrinking me into a small box pushing me
to one side and actually talking about a
real life time lapse what's going on
guys my name is David tomich I'm a
registered architect here in Western
Australia and today we are breaking down
the fundamental basics of an
architectural office so first of all
what do you need in this space and how
much space do you need well full
disclosure you probably don't need much
space at all you can probably get away
with a single desk and a laptop but if
you want to run a highly successful
extremely professional architectural
office there's a few critical things
you're going to need let's start with
the client first of all there are a
number of different meetings that you
need to have with your client to
interact with first of all of course the
introduction meeting and this can be
sorted in a number of different ways it
can be formal informal or via
so straight away you're going to need a
couple different spaces inside the
office to make it functional and work
for you we'll come back to them in a
little bit next you want to impress that
client along the entire Journey but you
also want to be able to do your work
from that space as well so breaking
these things down fundamentally you need
about three to four different spaces
which can potentially be condensed into
two to three spaces so let's start with
the very first one you meet the client
and you want to sit down have a cup of
coffee with them and understand what
their brief is you're going to need a
functional sit down space generally
speaking this is a very informal
discussion and it can either be done
over a lounge or a dining table so now
you have a couple options you can have a
boardroom table or you can have a lounge
Suite ideally I see this conversation
starting off in a very intimate setting
in a lounge Suite over a cup of tea or a
cup of coffee just getting to know the
potential clients after that it moves to
a boardroom desk and it actually
escalates to when plans are unrolled and
talked about so you're going to need two
space is here you need the Casual lounge
and you're going to need the boardroom
table now as this project evolves
there's going to be rolls of paper
sheets products all sorts of different
things you're going to need some space
that boardroom table becomes critical
for rolling out plans and discussing
alternatively you can still use that
Lounge suite and put a TV up on the wall
present that way which is also a great
functional way to do it because you're
not flipping through hundreds pieces of
paper however at a certain point in time
during that project you will need to
actually bring out some materials
discuss colors and talk about the
architectural principles in a bit more
detail which means ideally if you're
practicing by yourself or you're
practicing with a series of other people
you're going to need a materials Library
that's very specific very selective and
perfectly curated to your needs now the
materials library takes up a lot of
space and if you don't curate it
carefully it can take up way too much
space be completely unorganized and a
complete mess
so ideally if you're going to have a
materials and reference library you keep
that as a showpiece and very close to
those two spaces where you're
interacting with your clients so when it
comes time to actually present a
material palette mood board whatever you
want to call it you have the ability to
quickly go over and in between these two
spaces to continue presenting like it
was all planned for now for me this
vision is very simple it is the
boardroom table that we discussed with a
series of chairs around it to
accommodate for a large group most of
the time it's one to two people as your
client but occasionally you do have a
round table of Consultants that can go
up to 10 12 15 if not more people around
that table ideally you want to have a
boardroom table that can accommodate at
least eight people to start off with
from then you want to have a casual
Lounge Suite that can accommodate about
four to six people again the mixture is
constantly moving and changing so you
probably want to have a couple
individual sofas and also a two or a
three seater as well available to you
moving on to the material library and
ref reference library personally I would
love to showcase the actual physical
hard copy books that make the
fundamentals of architecture and have
built me as an architect then I'd love
to showcase the material palette of each
individual client as a showpiece of the
current projects running so for one
example what you could do is you could
have a long elongated series of drawers
all extremely small and thin because
materials are typically quite small
slabs swatches or anything in between so
you don't actually need deep drawers
unless you're going to build some larger
profile display sets these could come in
the form of claddings stone materials
wall panelings floor tiles Etc that you
just need that large format to actually
be able to present what it really looks
like a good example that comes to mind
is a kitchen bench top especially one
that's marble or Granite even Limestone
they are continuously changing in
pattern and a small little sample about
this big just doesn't cut it when you're
trying to actually Express the
architectural detail to the client so
large format tiles here are awesome and
potentially you could have a bank of
drawers at the bottom specifically
catered for this I'd foresee anywhere
from about 8 to 10 Banks of different
draws each categorized for different
products and samples we'll be talking
for all sorts of different things from
floor coverings Timber carpet vinyl wall
coverings colors skirtings even all the
way up to roof profiles sheeting Styles
and even gutters if you wanted to really
go into depth it is really ideal that
you can have all of these things on hand
keep the material Library updated and
fresh with your reps as they come in
because that's going to give you a lot
more ability to design better and in the
current market so as materials change as
pallets change you already have that
updated in your library ready to go now
this material library is a series of
Cabinetry which allows you to basically
piggyback onto that Cabinetry and create
a small little kitchenette in the office
you're obviously going to need a
microwave little fridge some sort of
coffee machine tea maker kettles things
like that just to be able to accommodate
the clients that walk into your door so
if you have the ability to integrate a
small kitchen into the office space go
for it ideally we're probably looking
about that 50 to 60 square meter Mark
which is a good comfortable size for I
would say a two to three to four person
practice at about that size you start to
get a little bit claustrophobic
especially with all those spaces going
on so I'd say it's about 60 square
meters for four people and then add a
little bit of square meter Ridge as more
staff come on board now we've covered
the client interaction consultation but
we haven't actually talked about
additional utilities that you're going
to need so yes you're going to need some
Plumbing fixtures and fittings but
you're also going to need some sort of
concealed printers hidden away in that
small office space architectural
printers especially large A1 or a0
printers incredibly ugly but they've
gotten a lot more Slimline and compact
so for example you can hide an A1
printer in a set of drawers or in a
Cupboard quite seamlessly and quite
easily if you clever about it and think
about it from day one otherwise you're
gonna have to put a smack bang on top of
the bench and it's just going to look
completely out of place a small little
comms room cupboard is going to be
extremely versatile just so you can
integrate all your it needs and your
phone lines it doesn't have to take up
too much space 600 by 600 is probably
more than enough depends on your
requirement now we've got the back wall
covered we've got the interaction with
the clients covered but what happens
when you need to go to the bathroom we
definitely need some sort of bathroom on
site to be able to facilitate this you
can't direct clients just hold it you
can't direct people to go somewhere else
you really want them to have a premium
experience when they go to your bathroom
a few of my clients have previously said
in the past this is what makes or breaks
a venue if your bathrooms are extremely
poor quality then the venue itself is
just tarnished no matter how good the
venue is people will come in say lovely
things and then walk back into the
bathroom go that was just a miss so the
bathrooms always need to be clean always
need to be pristine and they going to be
done to a very very high level okay so
now maybe these times actually focus on
the architect and the architects in the
office they need a little bit of space
some desks some chairs to actually do
their work ideally you want to be
running a desktop personally I find one
screen more than enough but two screens
is the industry standard so two screens
per staff member requires about 1.5
meters of desk space plus Papers Plus
drawers Etc so if you can allocate about
2.5 by 1 square meters per desk per
staff member you should have more than
enough room to actually integrate the
working and functional spaces into this
nowadays most architectural practices
Place their stuff on show these are the
people and the heroes behind the
architecture practice that make things
happen without a good team and without
the efforts behind every single person
then things just don't happen so that's
why architectural practices are
showcasing their workspaces just like
they used to do in the past where there
was warehouses full of people floating
in thin air drawing over large scale
paper it's a lot more condensed now
obviously but we are still on display so
you want to make this space as nice and
elegant and integrated as you possibly
can to be able to create this space
today I've used arcad 26 and the latest
twin motion
2023.1 which has come out just a couple
days ago the whole UI has changed
immensely and it is basically like
learning a whole new software once again
but so far the system is getting better
every single week there is one little
cheeky thing that I did in this video
here which was actually Implement a HDR
map from Google street view now if you
want to do the same thing I'll drop the
links down below just simply download
the Street Viewer to your computer all
you need to do then is copy the URL into
the Street Viewer export it as a JPEG
and then convert it to a HDR through any
form of converter both the websites no
affiliation I just thought it was a
really cool feature so you could import
any hdri Sky any Enviro directly into
your project and make it look as
realistic as possible anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and don't
forget about the like button if you have
any comments questions or concerns feel
free to leave them down in the comments
down below I will try to answer as many
as physically possible otherwise you can
join us on our Discord group it's 100
free the link is in the description like
I said that is all from me so I'll see
you next Monday